[Música]
una bienvenidos una vez más a canadá y
de las américas café que el programa
semanal de la sección en español del
radio canadá internacional este
encuentro digital que cada siete días
les proponemos desde este estudio
ubicado en la torre central de radio
canadá la única de más
empezando seriamente como cada semana
este espacio de seriedad y reflexión
desde la sección en español del radio
canal internacional como ustedes verán
la mesa está poblada hoy nuevamente está
aquí presente conmigo pablo gómez
barrios que tal como están cómo están
ustedes por allá del otro lado del
micrófono paloma martínez leonardo
gimeno hola mi nombre es luis laborda y
como ustedes verán en la punta de la
mesa tenemos una invitada que es
conocida una de las artistas más
renombradas que tenemos aquí en canadá y
en quebec en particular que es franca
presentarnos su nuevo álbum y que va a
salir a la venta en el mes de febrero si
el día de los
es un regalo ideal de semana está pasado
de una forma correcta y a tu gusto y
bueno a mi gusto siempre puede ser mejor
tampoco sin quejarse demasiado pero
bueno estamos aquí una vez más le
agradecemos a france que esté presente
aquí con nosotros vamos a hablar en
pocos segundos más con ella sobre su
nuevo disco que como ella dice va a
salir a la venta el 14 de febrero pero
que ya está presentando en vivo ya hubo
una actuación y hay varias fechas para
presentando en vivo en los próximos
meses pero antes de comenzar el diálogo
con florance como hacemos habitualmente
por costumbre siempre tenemos un tema
que nos ocupa que nos atrae la atención
en particular durante la semana y en
este caso es el brote de coronavirus que
está afectando a varios países en todo
el mundo esta enfermedad que ha
comenzado en el mes de enero
república popular china pero que se ha
extendido ya a otras naciones hay nación
en total en total si haya más de 200
personas muertas hay 8 mil infectados
eso solamente en china hay algunos casos
en otros países incluyendo a canadá por
el momento en canadá solamente tres
personas han sido confirmadas como
afectadas por este mal y las autoridades
han reiterado incluso hoy el propio
ministro primer ministro sustituto dijo
que no hay razones para preocuparse por
el coronavirus en canadá a ustedes les
ha preocupado ocupado el tema estos días
no a mí lo que me parece curioso y creo
que a mucha gente le parece curioso
louis es que bueno los canadienses que
están atrapados por así decirlo en china
están pidiéndole desde hace cierto
tiempo ya al primer ministro de canadá
que los repatríe que los traiga acá y
después de un largo periodo de reflexión
el ministro que estamos viendo ahí de
relaciones exteriores de canadá ya
campaña en la noche decían la televisión
que ya tiene en el avión que no son
amateurs pero lo que sorprende es que
dicen que las 200 personas que van a
venir no estarán sometidas a la
cuarentena y estas 200 personas vienen
directamente de la provincia de wuhan
entonces tiene desconcertado digamos que
esa gravedad que han tomado en otros
países en ciertos estados unidos por
ejemplo repatrió ya no también y los ha
puesto en cuarentena porque esos son los
principales riesgos de propagación del
mal tener gente que viene precisamente
de la ciudad que ha sido epicentro del
brote y que puedan empezar a circular
libremente por su propio país y eso
puede hacer que otra gente también se ha
contagiado
el canadiense que
en columbia británica si no me equivoco
si él se mantuvo guardado sin efectivo y
se mantuvo guardado durante varios días
hasta decir esto nada más y damos las
autoridades y gracias a eso hay nada más
que en dos o tres casos digamos si
existe un hombre se hubiera dedicado a
hacer una vida normal y salir y pasear y
tal es un hombre de negocios que visita
frecuentemente la ciudad de wuhan
precisamente con la responsabilidad por
las medidas que él adoptó ni siquiera su
familia se infectó ahora una cosa que es
importante decir es que ya varias
autoridades varios y varias instancias
en canadá ya incluso fuera de canadá han
estado diciendo constantemente que hay
que tener mucho cuidado hay que ser muy
cauteloso sobre la manera en la manera
en que hablamos de este virus porque no
hay que verlo como un virus sino porque
puede provocar toda clase de
tradiciones racistas y xenofóbicas
entonces hay que tener mucho cuidado en
la manera en la que uno se refiere a
este virus efectivamente los afectados
muchos de los objetos afectados digo los
que pueden transmitirle la enfermedad
estuvieron localizados en una región
específica de china pero no todos son de
origen chino primero y además ya hay
mucha gente en todas partes del mundo
que están pudiendo transmitir o no el
virus los virus los enfermeros no tienen
pasaporte exactamente esto no tienen
nacionalidad no tienen pasaporte es
fuerza y que tenemos mucho cuidado en
cómo se como se meten y también puede
afectar la gente que vienen de otros
países asiáticos exactamente la gente no
hace la diferencia necesariamente y
puede es un problema también claro el
responsable de salud pública lo
hablábamos con paloma esta mañana el
responsable de salud pública de la
provincia de québec horacio arruda se
manifestó sorprendido y repudió la
actitud de algunos padres que retiraron
a los hijos de la escuela porque en
en el caso en particular de estas
personas temen un peligro de contagio
por el simple hecho de que hay niños
pequeños y origen asiático en esas
escuelas en una sociedad multicultural
como ésta creo yo que no se siento a las
escuelas pero muchas debe haber gente de
origen asiático y de otros orígenes si
vamos a temer contagios o cualquier otro
tipo de problemas porque la otra persona
provenga de otro lugar
la cosa se basa difícil aparte de la
ignorancia van muy lejos porque es muy
probable que estos niños asiáticos que
van a la escuela jamás han pisado china
tercera generación
puede mantener no necesariamente tienen
contacto o están en la línea de fuego
entonces realmente es delicado y hay que
tener mucho mucho bueno lo cierto es que
esté mal hasta ahora ha afectado
mayoritariamente a china porque es donde
se originó el problema y además con la
enorme población que tiene ese país
asiático no es de extrañar que tengan
más casos que otras naciones
de todas maneras yo no sopesa 1200 ó
1.500 millones discutíamos con pablo
solo día de chinos que hay en china a
200 muertos muertes que por supuesto
lamentamos pero hay que reconocer que el
número de víctimas mortales en
proporción con la enorme población sigue
siendo bajo la provincia de wuhan tiene
40 y algo así un poquito más que canadá
pero lo siempre es que como dicen las
autoridades canadienses no hay razones
pero para preocuparse la propia
organización mundial de la salud dijo
que hay que permanecer calmos y no hay
razones para entrar en pánico pablo si
lo que inquieta a la gente es que ya hay
transmisiones de humano a humano que se
han hecho de este virus y se registran
en china alemania japón vietnam eeuu y
francia y eso es lo que comienza a
inquietar muchísimo las manos parece una
cosa
algo muy sencillo lunes pasado
pero es muy sencillo y es muy importante
las de las manos y cuando uno va al baño
cuando regrese al baño le mandaron un
comunicado la escuela donde están mis
hijos ubicados cuidado y no hacer lo que
acaba hacer louis los capaces con el
codo
pero hay una gran contradicción que
tenemos que hacer todas esas cosas y
prevenir el virus y que no hay garantía
es incomprensible porque como se puede
decir una cosa y después una otra cosa
entonces no sé a qué piensa el gobierno
de acuerdo primero y además que la
cuarentena no es una cuarentena como tal
son 40 días la idea y se están haciendo
cuarentena de diez días y dos semanas en
los miles de hoteles que de requisición
en que tienen
vacaciones pero bueno no es como
quarantine a como antes cuando los euro
europea nos vinieron hasta new york que
tienen en un centro terrible con nunca
eeuu estaba leyendo esta mañana está
hace un momentito que los que llegaron
ya desde la región de burbuja los
metieron directamente en una
para que se quedan ahí
los militares bueno esperemos que la
cosa se encarrile que no haya que
padecer más víctimas que no haya más
infectados en el mundo y mucho menos
aquí en canadá recién se refería el tema
a nuestra invitada de hoy que es franca
y ella no está aquí para hablar
solamente de coronavirus aunque ya se ha
referido al tema sino principalmente de
tu nuevo disco que se titula como franz
y qué característica particular tiene
este nuevo disco es mi primero disco
totalmente en francés bueno porque antes
yo trabajo mucho con músicos cubanos en
el lay en cuba también
desde 2 años soy la animadora de la
emisión se formidable en la civil que es
un show de radio que presenta canciones
en francés a la población inglés de
canadá y es muy interesante porque mi
trabajo es de tomar esas canciones y de
la de hacerles accesibles a la gente que
no habla francés y trabajar en francesas
y con música quebequense francesa por
dos años y medio en la luego el de ser
deseo de hacer música en francés
únicamente ahora por ese disco tú sabes
florales que por una cuestión de
derechos no podemos pasar los temas
musicales completos voy a contarlo
[Música]
para tener una idea de qué trata este
disco vamos a escuchar algunos
segunditos de cuatro temas que elegimos
al azar de no por ninguna razón en
particular y a partir de ellos vamos a
seguir hablando
esto
[Música]
antes
[Aplausos]
ese es el tema que abre el disco se
llama loncin y es la historia de una
mujer un adolescente bueno como 18 o 20
años que que muy interesando por la moda
por la imagen que vemos la imagen muy
importante en los servicios sesión
y redes sociales gracias mi español es
un poquito no está cantado
pero no se acuerda que toda la casi toda
la moda que tiene los vestidos son
hechos en condiciones terribles al otro
lado del mundo con productos muy
contaminados para un salario terrible y
que hay esa disociación entre bueno
estamos tratando de hacer un mundo mejor
pero las grandes corporaciones siempre
están haciendo más profitós porque si el
sujeto en partes del mundo donde las
condiciones no están así y para mí es
una cosa terrible y en mi vida no digan
más de trabajo y entorno de prueba así
con la música y el show bizz la moda es
muy importante y para mí
hice una cosa que en un año no compre un
pedazo de vestido siempre
reciclando lo o al ahmed y salió con
esas o algo con amigas para ver si era
posible de trabajar con la televisión la
radio de ir a mítines gala y todo con
una con vestidos que no son nuevos y de
moda young fashion y es totalmente
posible espero que en los años próximos
la conciencia general de esa cosa porque
no tenemos que culpabilizar a los
consumos
porque no tenemos otra posibilidad todas
las cosas se están haciendo entonces es
como para la música puede servir a eso
pero es el consumidor de todas maneras
ya que puede también hacer un aporte
importante a modificar la situación
vamos a escuchar una un segundo un
segundo tramo de uno de tus temas música
perfecta
el mar de ross mujer
[Música]
a mi ciudad
sí
y es la historia de un hombre que
trabaja muy muy fuerte
suceso bueno fiestas y que tiene
necesitan muchas cosas materiales
siempre más siempre más para tener
felicidad porque es como un guión de un
remolino si el ciclo de la sociedad de
hoy hasta que él se da cuenta cuenta que
no es feliz en irak
y es sobre la salud mental de los
los los hombres y como es diferente
porque tiene la presión de un tabú desde
generaciones y como tenemos que hablar
de esos porque los artistas sean
abiertos a hablar de la salud mental
pero es muy difícil en un entorno de los
saberes de business los abogados médicos
otros trabajo de hablar de eso es
todavía es muy tabú porque será que
hablamos poco de la salud mental de los
hombres si menos que de las mujeres
bueno lo que sé es que recibo muchos
mensajes de hombres en posiciones de
poder como útil tienen que ser fuertes
como policía porque buenos si en él
el ejército y que me dicen que no saben
cómo hablar de eso con los colegas con
los patrones con la familia porque son
ellos tienen que demostrar que son los
que están perfectos
más los suicidios en los hombres son
difíciles de comprender porque no hablan
de eso antes vamos a escuchar entonces
una tercera pieza muy perfecta
[Música]
vacío sólo estuvo delante
tranquilo se llama tranquilo porque
antes cuando viaje estaba buscando como
un adrián y adrenalina fiestas y siempre
conocer más de más y más y ahora cuando
viajo es que necesito calmo y necesito
abrirme a las comunidades a otras y de
recibir sus historias sus sonrisas y es
una canción sobre el cambio entre
poblaciones y entre gente intercambios y
al intercambio y los viajes que me
decías que últimamente no estás tan
dispuesto a viajar como estabas antes
antes yo quería viajar viajar viajar
pero siempre estaba estuvo buscando
suceso con mi carrera al al ahli con
afuera pero ahora es como si no necesito
esas cosas para ser feliz para mí estar
con mi esposo mi hija
casa es a veces más grande y ahora
cuando había viajo es para más
vacaciones o para descubrir otro país
ese no es como para el trabajo y mostrar
que puedo tener su acceso en otro país
vamos a [ __ ] un último tramo musical
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cultivó todo el año
imagine
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es una canción que se llama mínimo
mensual media noche sin ti y habla del
deseo y de la ausencia de la persona que
queremos tener en la cama con nosotros
de un amor un amor que es funcional
también que es que sano una sexualidad
sana también en estos días donde es tan
fácil de hacer contender y todo pero la
intimidad lo sabes así así así pero la
intimidad en una relaciones de confianza
una relación de ccoo mitada es también
muy bella no necesita hacer lo que
después de 10 años no me gusta más sabes
y es una cosa pienso que es importante
de saber que la intimidad puede crecer
con el tiempo y qué
dos personas el amor va a cambiar entre
dos personas en 20 años 25 años pero
cada forma de amor es válida como otra
ahora france a pesar de su juventud tu
trayectoria ya es bastante extensa
porque esperaste hasta ahora para grabar
un álbum en francés
pero me gustaba me gusta mucho la música
latinoamericana y no sé por qué es para
mí tocar montunos en el piano es uno de
mis grandes más grandes placeres y
también hay una proximidad con mi idioma
propio que quise quizás si no no estaba
pronta a decir las cosas en mi idioma
propio todos listos para gracias pronto
en italiano si hay pronto pronto
entonces eso y también es que hice 15
años de música latina y necesita
reinventarme pero sin dejar el lado
latino
en el espectáculo también
yo hago canciones de mi repertorio de
antes y tengo un percusionista cubano
que también
dan más cosas a la música ahora tú haces
música es tu actividad principal pero no
es la única
eres colega también que es tu propia
misión radio y como eso cuéntanos un
poco es fantástico me gusta la radio
porque es un medio de intimidad también
es un medio en donde la imagen no
importa puedo perder no es tu imagen
pero es una pero es es algo que es el
único medio aunque no ha cambiado desde
su instalación suena muy invención y la
gente todavía escucha la radio es como
si te necesitamos necesitamos ese esa
que nos habla
y hay algo que de nostálgico también con
la radio
que me gusta es fanática decidí ir es de
escuchar radio durante el día sí siempre
bueno en mi en mi coche es el puesto
donde escucho radio o cuando cocino
también que a veces no estoy siempre
escuchando lo que dice la persona pero
una voz y mi perra cuando me voy de la
casa
pero las dejó la radio ella no no no no
el agua para no y cuando me voy porque
está escuchando a radio canadá
internacional
bueno
y francés además de este disco que estás
lanzando próximamente tienes varias
actuaciones en vivo lo decíamos hace un
rato en distintas ciudades de la
provincia de québec hay proyectos hay
posibilidades de que más allá de que se
te vea en vivo en otros lados
yo me gustaría mucho también porque
todavía me gustan los viajes es sólo que
quiero más estar en casa también ahora y
estoy haciendo mis estudios un máster en
salud mental en mis cursos de ciencia de
serie porque quizá mi último sueño es de
un día poder ir a la escuela médica
y ser psiquiátrica pero es bueno sí pero
si no lo hago si estoy a mitad puede ser
psiquiátrica 51 años pero cuando la
juventud ahora durante los 70
también para cuando una actuación en
américa latina a una inflación en
américa latina me gustaría también mucho
hice un disco con mi amigo osvaldo
montes un compositor argentino un disco
para mi mamá que se llama colores donde
hay muchas canciones en español y se
ella se va de giro en américa latina yo
quiero ver si está ser su pianista
excelente plan me decías antes de
empezar emisión que te gusta el tango
ancha
te animarías a interpretar tango si
puedo cantar a capella algo que me
quieras nadar a nadar
para dorar
pero no me acuerdo de las letras pero el
día que me quieras' naranjo en flor me
acuerdo que una vez en buenos aires fue
el café tortoni para ver tangos
agravie dos canciones con bandoneón
también con walter y un gran tenista
amigo de osvaldo y los tangos y los
boleros son muy son primos y hay grandes
boleros como inolvidable como sabor a mí
también lágrimas negras que quiero
interpretar de manera tango también tu
familia es una familia musical tu mamá
hace música tu haces música tus hermanos
y hermanas también mis hermanas también
tienen una que está ahora con el giro
con el cirque éloize y la otra está
estudiando comunicaciones para hacer
como trabajando en la industria pero al
otro lado la cosa y qué pasa con tu hijo
mi hija tiene 13 años y está en
secundaria 2 y ya le gusta mucho la
ciencia pero quiere hacer el año próxima
está aplicando para hacer una inmersión
en español hace tres meses en españa
para meter el el idioma espero que
funcionara yo creo que puede tener
interés también en seguir una carrera o
una actividad porque sea paralela
también como artista o no tiene nada que
ver con ese mundo yo siempre le dije que
bueno si quiere hacer eso vale y la
bueno pero siempre dice o es tan bueno
ser yo logista amarillo
no ahora el estado las cosas han mucho
ha cambiado el lo vemos mi esposo es una
un baterista es que si necesitas una
gran confianza para hacerlo y de no
hacer ansiedad porque la cosa con este
mes esa profesión es la incertidumbre si
de todo bueno y necesitas como mi madre
lo puede hacer muy bien porque ella
tiene esa capacidad pero yo hago
insomnia si no tengo contactos y todo
eso es bueno para mi salud una cita con
renombre como el tuyo todavía pasa por
eso comentó de si también también no se
ve y la gente piensa que los artistas
porque no ven no ven en la televisión o
algo siempre es como fantástico y el
amor y todo pero no es verdad
bueno no para mí no sé madonna sí pero
yo no he llamado de una cuenta bancaria
que le permite estar bastante más
tranquila
sí pero pienso que un futuro con en el
medio medical o en la radio será bueno
para mí porque también a las 50 ahora
tengo 37 años pero en 15 años no sé si
me gustaría tomar la avant y conducir a
una niña como somos nosotros tú tienes
algún mensaje y aún así estamos lucas
dice salidas desde la ciudad de saludos
desde la ciudad de melo departamento de
cerro largo en uruguay y en francés dice
el jueves salió de floja dos hijos y la
cuestión si los hasta ese día en américa
latina si podemos contar con américa
latina
desde el 14 de febrero será
pero
pero no es bueno si me invita con el
boleto de avión
porque muy frío ahora hay muchos saludos
y bendiciones para todos ustedes
queridos amigos de radio caliente
nacional así como la invitada vasca creo
que su trabajo es musical es muy bueno y
llíria bill villalobos dice hola saludos
a costa rica
excelente transmisión pura vida entonces
para librarse de que gustavo es de
uruguay y javier gonzález nungaray es de
méxico cierto méxico y costa rica están
cubiertos con sudamérica centroamérica y
un poquito más y como siempre cuando la
pasamos bien y cuando tenemos una
invitada interesante e importante como
tú el tiempo vuela rapidísimo sabemos
que tienes que partir que tienes otras
ocupaciones te queremos agradecer tu
presencia aquí muchas gracias
queremos renovar la decirte que las
puertas están abiertas para cuando
quieras venir a este paso también te
pertenece y te esperamos para cuando
quieras mucha suerte con el álbum muchas
muchísimas gracias
y mientras florencia se retira quizás y
hablemos un poco de la aplicación móvil
internacional mire en la aplicación ahí
está el vídeo que han preparado aquí en
radio canadá para que ustedes vean cómo
funciona es nuestra aplicación la pueden
encontrar en el sitio internet de radio
canadá internacional en varias lenguas
pero sientan a la derecha siempre habrá
un espacio en el que ustedes aprietan y
hacen clic y entran a las tiendas más
conocidas de appple y de android
y ahí pueden escoger la lengua en la que
quieren bajar la aplicación a sus
teléfonos y a partir de ahí pueden
consultar nuestros contenidos en cinco
lenguas principalmente en el proceso
español chino y árabe
exactamente entonces así os dejamos
disponibles en nuestro sitio internet
www.sii.cl perfecto y qué tal si vemos
algunos otros mensajes de nuestros
oyentes de los que nos llegan por correo
electrónico
que tenemos y muchos días algún tiempo
sin leer pablo sí señor
publican en canadá manual de
inteligencia artificial para niños
eduardo gutiérrez cagüán si dice buenas
tardes primero felicitar a todas las
personas involucradas que han logrado
este material por otro lado preguntó si
el material tiene una versión para el
desarrollo del té
que es conocido en méxico como trastorno
aspect de espectro autista o síndrome de
autismo la razón es porque tengo un hijo
menor de 7 años con dicho síndrome y
busco las soluciones estoy atento
gracias que tengan bonito día y le puedo
comentar rápidamente cómo se llama se
llama eduardo gutiérrez caba ones bueno
eduardo si hay una vez hecho este esta
asociación lo que quiere hacer es crear
una versiones inclusivas que le llaman
para este tipo de la inteligencia
artificial para que los niños con
cualquier tipo de espectro de autismo u
otras cosas puedan acceder a la
información sobre el rodaje como dice el
código y aprender a hacer códigos y todo
sí sí sí puesta en español en inglés y
en francés moore no está en español por
el momento así que ojalá que lo pueda
ver yo aquí tengo una extensa un extenso
comentario de rodrigo vega
gamarra y cuervo sobre la organización
albert a facebook que lanzó a grecia la
campaña contra crudo y no se habla de la
división interna destruye una gran
nación más rápido que una guerra dice y
sobre todo cuando esa división ya no es
sólo el ámbito político para la disputa
del poder sino también en el terreno
peligroso del separatismo cuando una
gran nación pierde parte de su
territorio al dividirse es una o varias
naciones nuevas esa gran nación pierde
parte de su poderío y pierde asimismo el
respeto internacional y por tanto su
posición influye entre las naciones
del mundo y bueno en realidad el mensaje
es muy extenso así que queremos que
ustedes puedan ir a esta información la
organización de alberta facebook lanzó
agresiva campaña en contra tuyo y van a
ver todo el comentario y pueden
inclusive entablar una conversación con
rodrigo vega gabarre que es un tema que
trabajó para bloqueo lo hiciste bien es
cierto que tiene que ver con un
movimiento independentista separatista
autonómico en el oeste de canadá de más
de 200 grados que se acaba de aceptar el
vrac sit y justamente hay dos de los
países que conforman
la gran regla gran bretaña que estaban
hablando de separarse porque ya no es
ningún tipo de necesidad estar juntos de
hecho y este este grupo del oeste
canadiense llaman a este movimiento
separatista el wake sit
según justamente porque quiere quiere
separarse de canadá hay que recordar
aquí que en los conservadores
no lograron elegir
[Música]
andrews él no logró vencer a crudo y
crudo no logró elegir ningún diputado ni
uno solo ni en la provincia de alberta
ni en la provincia de saskatchewan que
son las dos provincias que están detrás
de este famoso website de este
movimiento separatista del oeste que son
las provincias que tienen un perfil más
conservador dentro de lo que es el
contexto nacional contento de cara en su
conjunto paloma con un mensaje de verdad
por favor
denuncian indigenización del sistema
carcelario de canadá y héctor dice son
víctimas de una sociedad invasora con
sus vicios y leyes los despojaron de sus
tierras trajeron el alcohol y otros
vicios y en sus mismos territorios las
mujeres son maltratadas o humilladas por
el machismo comentaba héctor a un
reportaje sobre justamente los altos
índices de personas de origen indígena
en las cárceles de canadá muy bien
muchísimas gracias por ese mensaje
también queremos dar lectura o por lo
menos
efe
un mensaje que nos ha llegado ya hace
tiempo que yo personalmente olvidé la
semana pasada empezó con este lado lo
encontré tarde el mensaje a la hora de
reclamar culpas vamos a pelearnos
también
en definitiva el mensaje que queremos
agradecer es de una de nuestras más
fieles oyentes que es graciela
mastrogiácomo que nos escribió ya hace
tiempo a mediados de diciembre en
realidad deseándonos felices fiestas y
que comenzáramos un 2020 con toda la
aventura que una buena amiga como ella
nos puede desear por razón de tiempo de
espacio y del mensaje que a veces se van
amontonando no habíamos dado lectura no
le hayamos contestado este mensaje hasta
ahora queremos decir a graciela y a
todos los oyentes y público en general
que nos sigue desde hace tiempo y por
las diversas plataformas que siempre
tenemos sus mensajes siempre los tomamos
en cuenta les agradecemos tomarse el
tiempo para escribirnos y para
comunicarse con nosotros de la manera
que sea estamos muy felices de recibir
este mensaje gracias y de todo
los oyentes y los invitamos a mantenerse
en contacto por el medio que ustedes
prefieran
siempre su mensaje son bien recibidos
bueno nos queda a todos nos queda algo
de tiempo para referirnos con un poco
más de calma de lo que hacemos
habitualmente a nuestros temas a los
temas que hemos ido trabajando a lo
largo de la semana como es tradición
cada uno de nosotros elige uno de esos
temas en particular y lo propone al
público en general como la cabeza de
como la como se dice el de batalla no
como la cabeza de proa de los temas que
hemos ido trabajando aunque otros tuve
mucho tiempo en reflexión para ver que
elegían de la inteligencia artificial
por favor bueno entonces quieres empezar
tú con tu tema como vos quieras bueno
adelante en realidad el tema está
titulado inteligencia artificial y los
trabajos del mañana resistir en la era
de los robots y esto tiene que ver con
un estudio que sacó él
sí muy bien muy bien no sabía que estaba
esto ahí el foro mundial el foro
económico mundial donde habla de
justamente estas 50 qué es lo que pasa
qué es lo que va a llegar qué es lo que
va a salir de esta gran revolución
industrial que estamos viviendo ahora la
revolución industrial la cuarta y qué
tiene que ver con la inteligencia desea
los robots y qué trabajos quedan y qué
trabajo no o cómo adaptarse porque esa
es una de las vías el tema de adaptarse
a las nuevas tecnologías para poder
mantener o generar un trabajo nuevo así
que el artículo es bastante interesante
también pueden ir a disfrutar lo que iba
a decir es interesante poder ver el
original de todo el estudio económico
mundial
les agradecería que bailan y visiten y
vean
así que los invitamos en w www rcn punto
o sea español y al final les dejo un
link que se llama will robot take my job
puntocom ustedes pueden entrar a hacer
clic poner cuál es su trabajo y les da
un porcentaje de la posibilidad de que
una inteligencia artificial o un robot
puede llegar a tomar el trabajo además
hablando ahora en serio este artículo
retoma alguna de las cuestiones a una de
las preguntas que la gente se hace
permanentemente ligados al ligadas al
tema de las nuevas tecnologías resucita
alguno de los fantasmas que no me
persiguen siempre llegamos a las nuevas
tecnologías si los robots no sólo nos
van a suplantar a sí vamos a perder
nuestro trabajo porque un dispositivo
computarizado va a poder hacer la misma
tarea
y dice en un par de tendencias que en
realidad lo que es el foro económico
mundial es que exactamente no va a
cambiar la manera de trabajar obviamente
va a uno tener que
en cuestiones que tienen que ver con la
tecnología pero que no nos van a
avasallar ni el día de mañana vamos a
estar todos a la vera de la tecnología
solamente en enseñar a los niños a hacer
códigos estatales eso es parte de esta
historia paloma su tema sugerido mi tema
de la semana fíjate louis que conversé
con los nietos de un coronel salvadoreño
que se llama josé arturo castellanos
hablé con álvarez y boris castellanos
que son canadienses y que son cineastas
y músicos y ellos le quisieron rendir
homenaje a su nueva abuelo porque fue
reconocido recientemente y desde hace
algún tiempo ya por haber sido un héroe
durante el holocausto porque salvó
muchísimas vidas de judíos en esa época
él era diplomático salvadoreño había
sido enviado como diplomático
salvadoreño a hamburgo y en hamburgo lo
que hizo fue emitir certificados de
nacionalidad salvadoreña a miles y miles
y miles de judíos que de otra manera
ha sido enviados a los campos de
concentración porque se hizo amigo de un
judío allá y entonces con ese es el lazo
como emotivo que desarrolló dijo voy a
utilizar mi impunidad y desobedeció al
gobierno salvadoreño de la época que era
por lo que parece bastante autoritario
entonces josé arturo castellanos ayudó a
salvar muchas vidas y por eso me gustó
hablar con simple procedimiento
exactamente tos hablé con los con sus
nietos que son casta canadienses y que
me contaron toda la historia así que las
las pueden descubrir ahí por temple w
punto digamos imágenes de un vídeo que
incluye en tu reportado extracto combine
de hecho el vídeo que es como la parte
del documental con las voces de los
nietos de éste desde coronel casa
ladrillo perfecto muchas gracias y pablo
sí señor bueno yo los invito a escuchar
un reportaje que hice sobre una mina que
se llama frontier y que es un proyecto
de mina en la provincia de alberta es un
mega proyecto es un proyecto de 24 mil
hectáreas de superficie que podría de
extracción de petróleo de las arenas
bituminosas de la provincia de alberta
está cerca de bueno cerca relativamente
cerca de fort mcmurray de la ciudad de
forma morí hasta 110 kilómetros es la
zona petrolera por excelencia de la
extracción de petróleo de las minas de
las arenas bituminosas y bueno este
proyecto es muy mal visto por los
ambientalistas que ven que que se quejan
no porque se van a perder tres mil
hectáreas de bosques vírgenes va a haber
14.000 hectáreas de humedales que van a
desaparecer y bueno entonces está todo
este el problema ambiental el gobierno
de ellos dentro do que es minoritario
tiene que debatir sobre ese proyecto y
se va a encontrar en aprietos para poder
hacerlo de un lado
de otro lado para guardar su imagen de
respetar el medio ambiente si para lo
material es algo que después de que nos
presenta este tema si hay tiempo quiero
decir una cosa pequeñita como no pero
para hacerla lo de pablo quería referir
que creo que son entendibles los temores
de las personas así porque no olvidemos
que hace muy poco tiempo sea unos años
solamente formal muy grande y toda esa
zona fue aquejada por uno de los
incendios más graves de bosques que hubo
en canadá en la historia del país y ya
ahí se perdieron muchas hectáreas de
bosques y de naturaleza sin que sus
temores son 24.000 hectáreas y yo muy
cortito para darle después ese espacio a
paloma un reportaje que hice esta semana
referido al uso que hacen los canales es
de sus teléfonos inteligentes es el
dispositivo electrónico preferido por
los canadienses para conectarse a
internet más que las computadoras
portátiles y que las de escritorio que
ya prácticamente han quedado relegadas
únicamente al ámbito laboral la mayoría
de los canadienses la enorme mayoría del
74 por ciento se conecta inter
usando su teléfono móvil hace que una
tendencia que va creciendo y como
contrapartida por ejemplo el viejo y
querido televisor va cayendo lentamente
en desuso si en realidad solamente
quería comentar que en cuba este este es
esta semana murió una mujer de origen
peruano pero nacida aquí en montreal y
la familia quiere repatriar el cuerpo de
jett lanzaron una campaña para recaudar
los fondos porque parece que es carísimo
retratar un cuerpo y complicado entonces
se trata de silvis a arabia sosa que
murió viajando con su bebé además
entonces nada más porque la gente quiere
ayudar a esta familia poder hacer eso
que está en nuestro sitio de internet
bueno entonces está disponible ya
también en ese tema para que ustedes lo
puedan consultar hemos llegado una vez
más al final de nuestra emisión el
tiempo se nos va volando
agua entre los dedos frase original si
las hay les agradecemos a todos ustedes
una vez más su presencia
otra frase que cortó muy bien muchas
gracias por haber estado una vez más
allí y los despedimos hasta el próximo
viernes que tengan una feliz semana